yeah and also tonight two democratic
senators are sounding the alarm on a
troubling new allegation claiming that
the cia has been secretly collecting
data on americans in bulk without
congressional approval for years now
this news comes after disturbing reports
that we revealed this week about the
capitol police spying on lawmakers and
citizens that go to visit them and
others now the new dhs bulletin on
terror is warning citizens against
mistrust of the u.s government and the
fbi is purchasing these nsos pegasus
spyware the most sophisticated spyware
ever made allowing those people that use
it and have it they will install it
secretly without any user knowledge they
could read your text collect all data
access your phone hear you film you do
it all but ask yourself why all of a
sudden do democrats care about spying
because they didn't really care when
donald trump was running and when donald
trump was president with reaction fox
news legal analyst greg jarrett harvard
law professor alan dershowitz uh you can
catch his podcast by the way
uh der show on rumble uh which is a
competitor to youtube professor
dershowitz let me let me start with you
one of the things that i have been
saying by not holding those accountable
for
lying to a fisa court on multiple
occasions using hillary's bought and
paid for dirty russian disinformation
dossier it's not verifiable it was all
debunked
by allowing that to happen
this now seems inevitable
so the their bulk data collections on
american citizens that would be
unconstitutional
in my view if they're using if we don't
hold them accountable on the fisa court
issue and then now the fbi is purchasing
pegasus from israel you see the
controversy going on in israel right now
it's a massive controversy that in fact
they use that information to get people
to testify against former prime minister
netanyahu that's a big deal
why would we expect it not to be abused
considering they would lie to a fisa
court and there's no accountability
i know i agree with you completely and
your constitutional analysis gets you an
a plus in constitutional law the law is
clear i'm a harvard professor i'm i'm
way out of my league okay
a low grader i was never a great
inflator uh you get the a plus uh the
constitution requires a search warrant
for any american citizen or american
person that includes permanent residents
now the cia has authority only to
investigate foreign threats to the
united states
sometimes when you overhear a foreigner
planning against the united states he or
she is talking to an american so
inevitably they may have to par listen
in part to what the american says in
order to get the full context but if
you're going to be spying on americans
specifically both the law and the fourth
amendment to the constitution require
that you get a warrant that you show
probable cause before you can overhear
the conversations and you know the
technology is amazing what israel has
done in terms of inventing pegasus but
it has to be controlled and that's what
the fourth amendment is about the fourth
amendment was designed at a time when
eavesdropping meant people standing by
the eaves of the house and listening in
today if you have a cell phone even if
it's turned off they can hear you and
that's why the fourth amendment is more
important than ever and that's why
you're right that by not holding
accountable the people who violated it
early on by lying to the fisa court has
led directly to i think this crisis in
the right to privacy under the fourth
amendment greg jarrett remember it was
andrew mccabe that famously said no
dossier no fisa warrant okay that was an
unverifiable document on the top of a
fisa application the word verified is
right there for everyone to see
we had four separate warrants signed
that it was verified that was false even
when the sub source of christopher
steele and christopher steele himself
denied what was in the dossier was true
now we're going to hand these same the
same group of people
even more powerful spyware where they
don't even need to go to a fisa court
and get approval
that's dangerous to me that's right
they they will either lie to the fisa
quarter circumventifies the court as
well as congress even though they are
under law uh required to do so but this
shouldn't surprise anybody since the
inception of the cia in 1947 there have
been widespread abuses in the 1960s the
cia launched
operation chaos spying on thousands of
americans for political reasons in the
70s the church commission found
illegal wiretapping bugging and
harassment of thousands of americans
congress passed a law to stop it it was
ignored by the cia they went on to
engage in warrantless wiretaps uh
illegal detentions uh torture and
kidnappings they even
they even spied on u.s senators more
recently by hacking into their computers
this sean is what happens when you
create an all-powerful government agency
that operates completely in secrecy and
is accountable to no one it needs to
change the first step would be to give
authority to the inspector general of
the cia who can't even subpoena
documents or report criminal activity
directly to the attorney general it's a
feckless position that needs to change
and congress needs to be made aware of
everything the cia does
we'll see what happens all right thank
you both hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else